economía de este 25 de agosto damos la
bienvenida y con mucho gusto al
especialista daniel a blandón daniela
pues la 1 naciones unidas ya hizo el
cálculo de cuánto ha perdido el turismo
en 5 meses de parálisis por la pandemia
del coronavirus si a las muy buenas
noches para hacer esta cuenta primero
hay que saber que 1 de cada 10 empleos
en el mundo corresponde al turismo y se
estima que el producto interno bruto
mundial perderá casi tres puntos
porcentuales por la pandemia como lo
explica el secretario general de
naciones unidas en los primeros cinco
meses de este año las llegadas de
turistas internacionales disminuyeron en
más de la mitad y se perdieron unos 320
mil millones de dólares en exportaciones
del turismo en total unos 120 millones
de empleos directos en el turismo están
en riesgos y como se sabe las áreas
líneas son de las más afectadas hoy
american airlines anunció que recortará
19 mil empleos si no recibe más ayudas
del gobierno de eeuu y la finlandesa
finnair dijo que prescindirá de otros
mil trabajadores
el hay que seguir hablando de más
industrias que ha afectado la pandemia
de coronavirus se desplomaron las
ganancias de los bancos en eeuu sí señor
la corporación federal de seguros de
depósitos que es una agencia
independiente supervisada por el
gobierno de eeuu indicó que los niveles
de liquidez y de capital de los más de
cinco mil bancos y corporaciones de
ahorro y crédito siguen estables sin
embargo lo que sí disminuyó en el
segundo trimestre fueron las ganancias
los casi 19 mil millones que lograron en
beneficios son apenas una tercera parte
de los más de 60 mil millones que habían
logrado en ganancia en el mismo período
del año pasado
eso habla debido en gran parte a que
muchos de los ahorradores que venían
honrando cumplidamente sus créditos de
hasta marzo pues se quedaron sin con que
pagar
y en latinoamérica daniela el congreso
de perú aprobó el retiro parcial de
pensiones públicas esto para hacer
frente un poco a la pandemia como lo
decíamos en el programa anterior este es
un nuevo desencuentro entre el ejecutivo
y el legislativo de ese país que de por
si tienen una relación bastante mala el
congreso aprobó finalmente el proyecto
de ley que aprueba este retiro con esa
medida se busca que los más de 47
millones de afiliados al régimen público
que no hayan cumplido los 20 años de
cotización a los 65 años de edad
reglamentarios puedan retirar hasta 1200
dólares de lo que tienen ahorrado pero
también que los 500 mil que ya están
pensionados reciban un bono de 265
dólares el gobierno calcula que si todos
sacarán lo que tienen el desembolso
sería de unos 5 mil 700 millones de
dólares y esa es la partecita que no le
gusta al gobierno ya que este sistema
funciona de esta manera los aportes de
algunos son la mesada de otros ahora
será el presidente martín vizcarra quien
decida si sanción al proyecto o lo
enviarte en un al constitucional
me genera mucho interés tu siguiente
tema daniela la curiosidad económica de
la jornada a la pues mira hablamos de la
cadena de restaurantes de pollo frito
kentucky fried chicken no sé si usted la
conoce yo creo que existe más conocida
como kfc si no es la más es una de las
más grandes del mundo junto con
mcdonald's pues hace más de 64 años casi
desde su fundación su eslogan ha sido
extinguir lyfc inglés que traduce algo
así como para chuparse los dedos pues
ahora con la pandemia del coronavirus
considero que esta recomendación resulta
algo inapropiada los cuando tenemos a
todas las autoridades de salud
pidiéndole a la gente que no se toque la
cara ni los ojos ni la boca por eso
decidió retirar este aviso de toda su
publicidad global en sus más de 40 mil
restaurantes ubicados en 140 países del
mundo en cambio va a promover el don't
like your fingers o no chupe estos leds
tus dedos aunque también advirtió que su
famoso lema estará de regreso pero sólo
cuando sea el momento adecuado
bueno pues seguiré las recomendaciones
entonces daniela va unos con indicadores
hubo cierre mixto en wall street su
principal índice cayó pero el segundo
más importante el estándar impulso marcó
récord histórico por segundo día
consecutivo las bolsas europeas cerraron
casi planas movidas por la noticia de
que china y eeuu mantienen sus
conversaciones comerciales y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo interrumpió
una racha de tres sesiones al alza
finalizamos con la cifra del día es bien
bonita son los 340 mil dólares que pagó
un coleccionista estadounidense por las
gafas del héroe de la independencia de
la india mahatma gandhi es una subasta
en inglaterra la que le permitió hasta
el señor adquirir estas gafas que fueron
entregadas a esta casa de subastas por
un hombre cuyo tío gandhi acusativo
gandhi se las había regalado en 1920 es
decir lleva 100 años en manos de esta
familia muchas gracias por este
recorrido económico daniela y gracias a
usted decía con más en france 24 punto
com